[Music]
does any of your like speaking ability
come from your love from wrestling and
cutting promos back in the day it's
funny a couple of wrestlers
hit me up on dm who are fans and they're
like dude you cut promos
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
and we are back for another casual
conversation with the classic and here
today with me is none other than
entrepreneur e-commerce legend
five-time new york times best-selling
author ceo keynote speaker
a mastermind with social media and i'm
saying that from someone who's read your
books and used your techniques myself
and for a lot of you that might not know
and what this is all about is a lifelong
fan
of professional wrestling
um it's true how are you doing today
gary vaynerchuk aka garyvee i'm doing
very well thanks for having me on the
show brother thank you for coming on i
really want to do this i always was
fascinated with the fact that you were a
wrestling fan i know there's a lot of
people out there that do know they might
have seen your interviews with the
undertaker or stephanie mcmahon or they
watch your podcast and they see the
figures in the background and stuff um
so i always was like man i would love to
talk to him about professional wrestling
and i would love for my audience to know
that you are a big professional
wrestling fan you're also part of this
extended family that we have with
professional wrestling fans so i want to
start off with asking like what were
your earliest and first memories of
professional wrestling what made you a
fan
god this is so fun to think about
because i really haven't thought about
it um
you know call it 84.
i'm trying to think about i don't think
i knew about wrestling you know don't
forget i was born in the soviet union
yeah so i come to the states i'm three
years old and 78
by 82 is kind of like
when i really started saying i became
americanized because those first
[ __ ] four years we were poor
like we barely had a tv like there was
you know so now i'm 7 82 somewhere
around eight or nine eighty three eighty
four i think hogan was already champ so
i don't think i knew he beat the iron
sheik in the garden
but i definitely knew about wrestling
prior to wrestlemania one
so much like most people in their 40s
if they didn't have parents or older
siblings that were into wrestling
they got hooked up
in that
incredible era of where cindy loper is
involved wrestlemania won
it all popped off in 84.85 for the rock
and wrestling era that's right
i
so you know there's people my age that
had the luxury it was funny there was an
older guy in my neighborhood
who used to tell me a lot of stories
this is all coming back to me now so i
got into it right then and immediately
there's a guy at the playground
i i'm guessing the guy was 30.
lived in the in the townhouse era and he
would tell me about
the key you know cola ivan koloff
beating bruno san martino with the knee
off the top rope in the garden
he educated me on like pedro don't
forget no internet yeah it's a different
era pedro morales
early doc you know because i knew who
dom the rock morocco was but young don
the rock
you know
and so not only did i get into what was
84 85 86 wrestling right wrestlemania
one the action figures that i have on my
shelf buying those watching every
saturday morning watching tnt when
mcmahon would interview people love that
show but i also but i also would
listen to stories on the bench parks of
the 70s a lot of 70s stuff so
i and and then i started buying
wrestling magazines at crousers which is
like a 7-eleven
so now i'm like learning like the
missing link and like
you know like the blade runners and like
all these other like what's uwf and who
are the von eriks and then in 86 87.88
that stuff started showing up on espn
the dingo warrior yeah you know so i was
not only wwe but i was like nwa
i was you know awa
i was really a wrestling head and would
like get super pumped when like bad news
brown would come to the wwf i'm like
that's bad news balance like you know
like i was really into it
and it was a core part of my
entertainment i mean my first sleepover
party and as a you know because if
you're from an immigrant family you
don't have sleepovers that often so my
first sleepover party was summerslam the
first summerslam
it was a huge part of my childhood we
wrestled outside
i made wrestling figures by drawing and
cutting my v friends today and of course
a lot of my drawing came from drawing
wrestling figures cutting them out on
paper and then putting them on cardboard
and gluing them so i could actually
wrestle with them like it was a very
from 85 to 90
it was 84 to 90 that five six year
period
outside of jets football yankees
baseball and video games and just being
a kid and doing and then my
entrepreneurial stuff shoveling snow
selling lemonade it was a top five thing
in my life
100 yeah a lot of that's really
relatable i can relate to a lot of that
in a sense and it's crazy out still with
you tell today like i saw that video on
youtube recently um i know it's been out
for a while but that one where you're
unboxing all your lgn figures and you're
asking your
assistants and stuff like you know who
the son they didn't really know what her
and you were like a little bit
devastated so like how do you know this
person how do you not know that person
um how does it feel for you when you got
those figures was it sort of more of
like like when it comes to collectibles
i mean you know so much of what i do now
if you're listening right now
go to youtube and type in trash talk
garyvee there's a show i put out
you know i talk a lot about like ways to
advance your career and
i started noticing a lot of people
talking about well gary i don't have any
money like cool that you invested 25 000
into tumblr and it turned into a million
i don't have 25 000. and i was like fair
point i was in a different point in my
life when i was in my teenage and 20s i
would garage sale a lot i made a lot of
money on ljn's and hasbro action figures
yeah you know i would buy
50 hasbro's at a garage sale for 10
bucks and then go list dusty rhodes or
andre for [ __ ] 50 to 100 bucks by
himself right so
and i literally i literally just wrote
an article for 1 37 p.m about the 15
rarest and us figures for you guys i
love it i got to read it
i just wrote that for you
you bought up two of them that were on
that list and that was the andre and the
the dusty world's husband
yeah and i bring it off off top of my
head because like i'm actually trying to
see if i can find the article i'm
talking to you um you know it's it's
it's what i you know there it is love it
i'm gonna share it right now my twitter
give you a little love thank you thank
you you're welcome um
you know
i it was just such a i say that off the
top of my head because i really know
right like i know what black card ljns
are like
i know my [ __ ] like i'm really in this
like i i watched most of the saturday
night's main events i watched the you
know the first
10 wrestlemanias like this is a culture
i really know
um and love and
so you know
for me the lgn thing was really fun as a
matter of fact this is not a joke
literally watch this if you're listening
on podcasts you won't be able to see
this but i'm going to show you something
that's going to blow your mind of how
big of a part of my life this is so this
is my ebay i'm just showing you and then
obviously this is my ebay account the
last thing i looked up i guess was psa
but watch this i hope it's
there don't know how they do it yeah if
you're on youtube guys you can check
this out right now and yeah go check out
that article guys i wrote a handful of
articles from 1 37 p.m and that was the
most recent one i just did and it was
about the most rare expensive figures as
of today yeah look at this look at this
look at the last look at the last thing
i searched on my ebay account there we
go lgf
ljn wwf the last thing you can search so
it's like just in me like it's a very
big part of my culture 80s
and 90s wrestling
was humongous for me and i actually
might have 11 year younger brother aj
so
what's funny about that is his age lands
so his golden year so i got him into
wrestling yeah but his golden era was in
between hogan and the attitude era okay
so aj like [ __ ] with like tatanka and
like dukes of dunks rosie and [ __ ]
like yeah that yokozuna brett heart era
before we went into stone cold and the
rock right yeah so i was you know
ludwig borga and [ __ ] luger and like
that kind of that era
and so like it's just always because
once i got out of it very quickly behind
me my brother is now like i'm like this
is steamboat and this is you know this
is tugboat excuse me and this is
earthquake and like that video game came
out and so like it's kind of just been a
constant heartbeat for me
and i can relate to that too my older
brother's 10 years old than me and i
don't think i'd have been a rapping fan
he was born in 1981 so he lived through
hulkamania that was his thing i was born
in 91 so i lived through that same
breadheart yoko attitude period so i can
totally relate to that as well i uh
being a fan of yours obviously i've
watched your videos that follow you on
instagram for years and stuff um read
your books crushing at someone that i
was referring to earlier because doing
what i did with the wrestling classic
was a lot of reading that book on a
plane going to wrestlemania 32 and being
like oh just slide in the dms don't
worry about it
okay i got this and i started
implementing that in my own stuff that i
started doing once i realized
that this whole wrestling classic thing
could be something i didn't know it at
first i was just doing it for fun and
then i went to dallas and people were
wearing my shirts that i printed for fun
for uber money and i was like oh people
actually are about this and your book
helped me a lot with that but that being
said
i love your wheels i love your tick
tocks i love your quick motivational
videos and stuff i always wondered
does any of your like speaking ability
come from your love from wrestling and
cutting promos back in the day
so would you ever get in touch with your
wrestling side like i'm gonna cut a
promo is that like part of it
not only is it a part of it yeah i
actually think it's
the i think basically garyvee the
communicator is a mix between randy the
macho man savage promo
and
chris rock and
eddie murphy and
i mean the amount of richard pryor eddie
murphy chris rock i listened to yeah in
combination to wrestling promo yeah i
mean like sometimes it's actually too
ridiculous like i caught a
video
six or seven years ago for
a conference i was keynoting and they're
like hey like my team came in they're
like gary
you know would you uh you know they're
just that the ticket sales aren't going
that strong would you do a quick video
to tell everybody about this social
media conference and literally this is
what came out of my mouth i'm like hey
guys it's garyvee civic center march
19th nine like i was like and then i
stopped like oh my god this is literally
a [ __ ] i've heard something and i'm
like i'm like this sounds like a
wrestling promo to me it's funny a
couple of wrestlers yeah hit me up on dm
who are fans that are like dude you cut
promos and i'm like
i'm like i do i know it took me i didn't
know it for five or six years of the
garyvee [ __ ] but then when somebody
pointed it out and i really started
getting into my feelings on it i'm like
yeah i think i think quite a bit i think
a lot of my content now
is clips from my day-to-day life so it's
a little bit less
but my rants
which were a big part of my 2014-16
content and i just did one the other day
i feel that they're like flat out
wrestlemania promo videos yeah because
that's what i felt like i would watch
him like i know he's he's meaning what
he says but i know this is influenced
from wrestling i can tell 100
it's subconscious right yeah like he has
that promo skill
um do you have a favorite promo like i
know macho man's one of your favorites
of all time he's gonna be copying the
big time or something but yeah i mean i
think my favorite is when he's
outside by the pool
oh the mean gene and elizabeth that's
right and he goes that mean gene there's
a plane going by and i'm not on it like
and i'm like
i don't know what it the cup who rises
to the top is all time but for some
reason there's a plane going by and i'm
not on it i don't know what it was
that but i'll tell you what my favorite
was okay my favorite was
the macro concept of getting us into a
frenzy before somebody was actually in
the in the federation yeah by the time
mr perfect and razor ramon were actually
in the ring
i was completely out of control into
both of them yeah those videos perfect
and i think that was the brilliance of
vince mcmahon and the wwf
slash e like to me
they they just did such a great job in
storytelling
that
that you were just salivating to watch
one of these guys beat the [ __ ] out of
iron mike sharp or canine or barry
horowitz you know back then wrestlers
beat up nobodies on saturday morning it
wasn't all these big matches yeah to
build the star correct yeah they did the
boxing thing right they took a bunch of
easy fights and
i mean
i mean
that's corporal kirchner like even guys
that most people don't know as well like
the hype
was just so fun but what really stood
out was razer
and perfect because they really had
those guys
in a frenzy before they even came in
saturday morning and beat somebody up
they were so creative and so good like
the wonder razor pushes the guy into the
fountain he's like don't have luck like
him
and perfect just doing the bowling and
the golf
and it's crazy because obviously as you
get older you realize it'd be like that
whole football thing throwing it across
the field and him running and catching
you know it's cut in certain things but
i've been pretty like whoa he actually
did that that's crazy oh as a kid you're
like king kong bundy broke hogan's ribs
and you're like so upset and like
as a kid it's just [ __ ] awesome i
think that's the biggest thing about
professional wrestling though right it
captures you as a kid because you have
that imagination and you only grow to
love it as you get older because you
ever get that question how do you still
like this like this ufc how do you still
like this i'm always like because now i
understand it as a form of like art like
it's like well i i i like it in the way
that i like watching queen's gambit yeah
the way that i watch you know a show to
me it's story line i mean i think
wrestling is
male soap operas it really is you know
like more character storyline that
really fascinates me now as a creative
entrepreneur and a marketer and a
storyteller
there might not be anything i'm more
interested in wrestling as a matter of
fact literally yesterday
i said to somebody i can't wait to see
who triggers the next
monster wrestling era literally
yesterday i said
hogan
stone cold and rock
somebody it feels like wrestling's doing
its thing but it's very much now like
like you know
brock undertaker the rock doing
wrestlemania
we don't have
must-see people like i don't feel like i
need to watch raw yeah no 100 percent
but i feel like
what i love about wrestling is
at any moment there's some kid right now
who's coming up the ranks
who's gonna be the human being
that completely captures the national
attention
and for another 24 to 39 months
everybody's gonna know
xyz the name and it's gonna make
everybody watch
raw every monday night and that's and i
think i think and to your point like
they just kind of brought back john cena
for that reason because they haven't
really built any stars right now that
has catapulted the wrestling back in
that thing but yeah it's funny me and my
friends when i'm like going or like kind
of paying a little more attention i take
i like
guessing i i like saying
i see they're trying to push this guy i
don't think he's got it right and and i
like to test my ability of like having a
sense of like
charisma and the consumer and yeah i
don't feel like they've pushed the right
people recently have you given aw a
chance at all
a little very little bit like my
wrestling right now in the last three
years i'm just so underwater and
definitely with when kobet hit in the
last you know 15 16 months i just had so
many responsibilities to make sure
i was on the offense business wise yeah
that but but it keeps going down to the
same thing which is like
uh you know i follow it on social
yeah
but i haven't been able to like really
really allocate like the way i like to
do it when i'm like oh let's do this
like i need four weeks of like following
the storylines to really get captivated
by
the charisma of the characters and i
just haven't been able to give
anybody that
right now i uh not to be another cheap
plug but if you ever need a catalog i
did also write an article on the 20 top
aew matches
that that's such a good point like what
i'm not as good of a reader what i'll
probably do is go watch the youtube
versions of that yeah
because that's what i need to get like
interested no for sure and i just think
it's a good calorie what's the best one
what's that what did you do what did you
decide was the best one uh for me i
think it was between uh cody and dustin
but that's also because once again i'm
also a character storyline guy and
there's a really good story there
between the two brothers and whatnot and
um
it was if you watch that magic you feel
like you're being told a story rather
than just watching a match with a bunch
of acrobatics and i don't know what's
happening definitely check that out yeah
i'm i'm
way more like way more story than i am
performance a hundred percent
i love performance no no i mean [ __ ]
rey mysterio jr and eddie like some of
this stuff is just outstanding the
performance stands out more if you're
intrigued by the characters in the story
yeah and i if i'm intrigued by the story
can overlook poor wrestling 100 right
like hogan hogan warrior wrestlemania is
not iconic wrestling
but the story is [ __ ] in that
building the ultimate scene was insane
just to see those two eye to eye was
like a moment and that was but but on
the flip side performance like when you
watch
piper bread heart
wrestlemania where piper really puts
brett over
like it's a very underrated moment in
wrestling history because it's like a in
that pocket of like in between
90 i think one which was like a
transitional time in a sense
i just think that
when you see stuff like that
because piper's such a good wrestler too
and brett you know
there's no story there because brett was
the up and comer and piper was the
champion the intercontinental champion
knows his time to get that singles and
so like the story always does kind of
make things and elevate things more and
if the story is really good you'll be
invested in the match if they're just
really good wrestlers and the match is
even more memorable because that's right
you know what i mean um i'm gonna ask
you this a little bit more of a fun
question since you're an old school fan
and you grew up watching wrestling
say you are a manager so you were bobby
henan okay you're gonna start your
garyvee family and be friends you can
call it yeah nft stuff
who would be on that survivor series
team of five who would be your five guys
macho man randy savage yeah who's
disproportionately my favorite wrestler
of all time here it's something i agree
with fully um
okay let's really i really want to give
you a real answer so i'm going to really
think this through um
uh
y2j
yeah
i love chris jericho
i've always loved jericho
um
i would say
i'm i i usually to give fast answers but
i really want to think this through
because i don't want to hear the
[ __ ]
uh
i would probably put the british
bulldogs on there davey and dynamite yes
because because i'm thinking about like
who did i really love like genuinely
love and i would say the british
bulldogs
were the closest thing in my prime to
macho man yeah um
and then
i'm probably going to go
well if i can blend leagues since the
wwe now owns them all yeah my favorite
this is your dream team this is yours i
would go with nikita koloff the russian
sickle yeah the russian sickle is still
one of my favorite finishing moves he
was just so [ __ ] badass and i still
always had an underlining feeling
towards russia since i was from there
and so i would say macho man
the british bulldogs
jericho and the kitakova that's a stack
team with different styles of wrestling
right they got a powerhouse you got some
flamboyance you got the tag team that's
good stuff right there it's a summer
team no for sure let's talk about the
watchman really quickly um because he's
my favorite of all time to you once
again that also goes back to i think i
like my imagination being captured as a
little kid this guy was on like wwf
mania and whatnot just all california's
cowboy hats and whatnot um what made you
a macho man fan what made you like
because during the time of hulk mania
almost everybody was a whole community
it was always hogan hogan my brother was
hogan hogan i i realized in my old
something happened later in my life when
like i didn't like tiger woods or kobe
bryant and then when they were older i
loved them yeah and i and when that
happened in my 30s i was like oh
this is just a very recent realization
i feel like i'm an underdog i love
underdogs to your point everybody loved
hogan
i didn't want to be like that and so i
decided um
uh you know
i really want uh
to be different the other thing that
happened was if you remember the story
line everybody was buying for macho man
that whole manager thing
well miss elizabeth i still think hogan
was the heel there that he had lost in
his eyes for elizabeth i'm just i'm
gonna
say so when when
when he goes and i thought it was going
to be slick i remember i was like like i
was like slick's gonna get him oh when
you when he was vying for a new manager
yeah and when he said my manager is
eliza and she comes down
you know you got to remember i'm like 10
11. yeah and like i'm not sure but i
think that might have been the moment i
became a man
yeah so between so between
between
underdog
and then he was such a great wrestler
right like if you're like if you watch
if you watch that tito santana match
that he wins
i mean then obviously [ __ ] the ricky
the steamboat match
i'm so pumped that that is like the
greatest match of all time it means so
much to me that's storyline that was
tough for me a little bit
because you're a steamboat fan i wasn't
but i liked them
yeah but it was so nasty like the throat
it was like it just seems
but i stuck with him through and through
um i loved georgie animal steel because
the jets were my favorite team and he
had a green tongue and that was big for
me
um so
yeah i think it was the combination of
miss elizabeth
at the age that i was
being counter different
and just the charisma and like who he
was it was just the complete package um
i know we're gonna wrap this up soon so
i want to ask you this really quickly as
well the big question
um
take time to think about it i feel like
we've touched on it a bit here and there
but at the end of the day like
why is wrestling important to you
it's because outside of walt disney i
think vince mcmahon has been one of the
most significant storytellers of
characters in our society yeah and
i think
the friends being one of the most
important things in my life for the next
50 years is going to make sense to why i
always was associating to
transformers wrestling gi joe disney i'm
a storytelling character based human
being and i think wrestling's unique
because unlike
wrestling everything else is fictional
this is like real humans that play these
characters but it's storytelling and i
think it's been the most significant
storytelling
machine in our society
and uh
and that i admire
i love that i like to call it the
greatest form or an athleticism because
it's the one that puts both of them
together
and it's amazing i think i think dana
white has a lot of don king meets vince
mcmahon like i think he's why ufc so
incredible is
it's like slightly the reverse thing
right which is it's real life
but they do such a great job getting you
excited about the fighters and that
matters that's what great promoting no
matter how much people want to say ufc
is real and it's not they took a lot
from professional wrestling to get you
hyped yeah and and and vice versa right
yeah like like wwf wwe excuse me now is
very much affected by
and and obviously has done a lot with
the angles and
and
and shamrocks and you know like
and bobby and like so like it's it
they're good for each other in my
opinion yeah they do they work well on
look if brock didn't go to ufc and come
back being the brock lesnar he was
[Music]
because i am a fan of yours and i've
i've listened to your speeches and i've
read your books and i follow you on
social media you always say take
advantage of all the opportunity again
i've had the opportunity to sit here
with you so i'm just going to throw it
out there there's anything you ever want
to do in the future that is wrestling
related i'm your guy
send me an email literally send me an
email right now i want to save that in
the folder sure because the last seven
years i've been running this page i've
made a ton of relationships with
wrestlers within the industry and people
that work backstage as well as a valued
voice with the fans i've been crapping
on john cena all week but they still
love me that's who
that's how close we are you know what i
mean so i love you i'm more than happy
to send me that email right now i'm
opening it for sure
i got my articles at 1 37 pm too so
cheers
thank you for your time i really
appreciate it thank you brother you're
doing the thing
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment and
exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you